apprentis d'uteuil aide chaque année
près de 40000 jeunes en difficulté à
bâtir leur
[Musique]
avenir allez on va la tourner tout le
monde en place et action Michel regardez
votre programme aveconi et michelnaref
qui ne serait pas là s'il avait mieux
géré son épargne et je fais quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public votre
rendez-vous qutidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat on est
ensemble tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts nos
chroniqueurs et nos reporteurs la trêve
se prolonge à Gaza mais jusqu'à quand
cette question tout le monde se la pose
des familles d'otage détenu depuis 54
jours diplomate du monde entier en
passant par les civils palestiniens qui
redoutent la reprise des combats qui
mène les négociations le Hamas c'est-il
précisément combien d'otages sont
toujours vivants la guerre peut-elle
reprendre sous une forme différente on
en débat dans une minute et puis dans
l'actualité de ce 29 novembre il y a
aussi la COP la COP 28 qui s'ouvre
demain à Dubaï je vous propose un zoom
sur l'une des conséquence majeur du
réchauffement climatique la fonte des
glaces
polaires
vous entendez parler du réchauffement
climatique mais ici on constate c'est ça
le
message les gens qui vivent ici ceux qui
viennent souvent comme nous on voit les
glaciers on peut témoigner d'une mission
à l'autre quel est l'impacte du
réchauffement
climatique monté des EAU réfugiés
climatique nouvelle route commerciale
exploitation minière nouveau virus la
liste des défis est longue très longue
vous le voyez ne ratez pas l'analyse de
de nos invités dans trois quart d'heure
mais d'abord donc la situation en Israël
et à Gaza alors que le ramas propose de
prolonger la trêve de 4 jours Jonathan
duprieèz vue désert Gaza ressemble à un
champ de
ruine au sud de la ville les riverins
constatent incrédule que leurs
habitations ont été ravagées par des
semaines de combat c'est tout ce qu'il
reste d'une vie de labeur ce que j'avais
de plus cher était dans cet endroit mes
enfants mon mari même s'il n'est plus de
ce monde j'ai travaillé si dur pour leur
construire cette maison et en l'espace
d'une seconde tout a disparu au 6e jour
de trêve la bande de Gaza vit un court
moment de répi répi que les
organisations internationales jugent
bien insuffisant au vu de l'ampleur de
la crise humanitaire qui couve la moitié
des hôpitaux de l'enclave sont hor
service quelques 30000 blessés seraient
en attente de
soins à terme les maladies vont tuer
plus de personnes que les bombardements
si nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
remettre en place ce système de santé et
de fournir des denrées vitales de base
de la nourriture de l'eau des
médicaments et bien sûr du carburant
pour faire fonctionner les hôpitaux si
la trêve a permis de faire entrer les
ONG dans Gaza elle a surtout permis de
libérer un important contingent d'otage
81 à ce jour échanger contre 180 détenus
palestiniens les médiateurs
internationaux Qatar Égypte et surtout
les États-Unis se démultiplie pour
obtenir un arrêt durable des combats le
secrétaire d'État américain se rend en
Israël en ce sens au cours des prochains
jours nous nous efforcerons de faire
tout notre possible pour prolonger la
pause afin de pouvoir continuer à
évacuer davantage d'otage et apporter
davantage d'aide humanitaire le Hamas se
dit prêt à prolonger la trêve de 4 jours
et une nouvelle libération d'otage
pourrait avoir lieu ce mercredi de son
côté l'État hébreu affiche toujours sa
fermeté Benjamin netanahou a réaffirmé
vouloir libérer tous les otages du Hamas
et prévient qu'Israël reprendra les
combats après la trêve
combien de temps cette trêve peut-elle
durer on en débat avec Anne Sophie sban
bécage bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice de l'American gwish commite à
Paris et docteur en géopolitique
Guillaume Ansel bonsoir et bienvenue
écrivain ancien officier auteur du blog
ne pas subir ééonor veille bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
indépendante vous avez notamment
travaillé pour le quotidien israélien àz
et Matthieu croissand éditorialiste
politique bonsoir Mathieu cette trève
elle est fragile Anne Sophie c'est bambé
cche qu'est-ce qui pourrait
l'interrompre aujourd'hui ce qui
pourrait l'interrompre c'est la décision
de l'armée israélienne de reprendre
l'opération militaire euh pour euh finir
de remplir les objectifs qui s'étaient
fixés c'est-à-dire de de neutraliser euh
la capacité de nuisance la capacité
militaire du ramas elle se finit
normalement cette trêve euh demain il y
a des négociations en cours pour qu'elle
se poursuivent euh les les possibilités
pour qu'elle se poursuiv vont dépendre
de la nature de ce qui est euh de ce qui
pourra être négocié de ce qui F figurera
dans cet accord mais certains enfin ce
qui pourrait conduire Israël à à
accepter un accord qui permettrait de
poursuivre la trêve ce serait la
libération de tous les otages mais aussi
la la démilitarisation de Gaza le fait
que ramas le ramas dépose les armes
voilà ça pourrait être un moyen de de ne
pas de ne pas poursuivre cette opération
militaire mais les objectifs d'Israël
sont dans les enfin sont les mêmes ils
ont été rappelés il ne risquent pas de
de changerad le Hamas et de l'empêcher
de de nuir Guillaume el pourquoi le
Hamas propose une trêve plongée de 4
jours est-ce que c'est c'est lié au
nombre d'otage qu'il est sûr de détenir
d'une certaine façon parce que c'est une
vraie question ça ouis en fait une
question qui est cruciale dans cette
négociation sur la libération d'otage
c'est que aucune des deux parties ne
sait exactement combien d'otage il y a
les Israéliens avaient estimé d'ppord à
240 on pense que assez malheureusement
naturellement il y en a une vingtaine
qui ont dû mourir en arrivant sur Gaza à
cause de leur leur blessure initiale ou
des mauvais traitements qu'ils ont reçu
c'est un total de 220 il y en a 90
aujourd'hui qui auront été libérés
faites le décomte il faudrait réintégrer
à l'intérieur le nombre d'otages qui ont
été tués pendant l'offensive israélienne
qui mon avis sont quasiment aussi
nombreux donc en fait on sait pas très
bien si on reste entre 60 et 100 pas
plus et donc les Israéliens sont très
méfiant et ils ont raison de l'être
parce qu'en face le Hamas ne sait même
pas combien d'otage il lui reste en vie
réellement parce que les otages pardon
nous interrompre ils ont été entre
guillemets dispatchés au sein de
différents groupes différents lieux et
cetera on sait que les les otages dans
ces situations-là sont toujours
dispersés parce que ce serait prendre
des risques énormes que d'avoir un seul
groupe on imagine mais c'est assez
courant dans ce genre de malheureusement
situation que ce sont des groupes entre
5 et 10 otages donc ça fait une
quarantaine de cellules différentes qui
ont été réparties sur l'ensemble du
territoire de Gaza comme les Israéliens
ont détruit à peu près un/ers de la
bande de Gaza avec les bombardements
tout toute façon mécaniquement on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de cellules
qui ont été détruites mais que le Hamas
ne connaît même pas parce que ce sont
des équipes des cellules qui sont très
mal coordonnées et donc les patrons du
Hamas avec qui on essaie de discuter au
Qatar ne savent pas quelle est la
réalité sur le terrain et les Israéliens
ont une liste qui ne veulent pas
dévoiler pour l'instant de d'otagees qui
sont décédés mais ils attendent de
savoir ce que le Hamas va mettre sur la
table pour dire non ça c'est c'est pas
vrai et d'ailleurs c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles le Hamas refuse que la
Croix-Rouge internationale aille visiter
les otages parce que un ils savent pas
où ils sont et deux ils veulent surtout
pas qu'on sache quelle est la réalité du
nombre qui reste ééonorveille la société
israélienne est-ce qu'elle est partager
sur cette question que pèseent ceux qui
militent pour une reprise des combats
écoutez c'est c'est un dilemme
aujourd'hui qui frappe la société
israélienne parce que d'une part il y a
quand même cette ce ce ce débat autour
de de la sécurité de recouvrer un
sentiment de sécurité après les
massacres du 7 octobre mais aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il y a quand même un
consensus on peut dire qu'il y a un
consensus autour aour de cette priorité
qui est le retour du plus d'otage
possible et tant qu'on a l'espoir de
retrouver ses otage en vie la majorité
des Israéliens mis à part une petite
partie de l'extrême droite israélienne
et pour cet objectif de guerre
contrairement au premier qui avait été
affiché qui est l'anilation la
destruction du Hamas aujourd'hui voilà
ce que ce que disait monsieur Ansel
c'est effectivement le Hamas prétend
qu'il ne peut pas aujourd'hui localiser
l'ensemble des otages on a entendu
surtout cette famille Bibas dont on
parle beaucoup ces dernières heures ces
dernières semaines on va on va sûrement
reparler qui sont devenus vraiment le
symbole hein de cette de cette prise
d'otage et qui serait aujourd'hui aux
mains du FPLP donc un autre groupe à
l'intérieur de de la bande de Gaza mais
il y a aussi cette crainte que le ramas
joue un jeu cynique en ne pas voulant
divulguer ce qu'il sait ou ce qu'il ne
sait pas en jouant aussi sur cette
complexité de retrouver les otages pour
prolong le cesser le feu ça fait aussi
partie du jeu de guerre du du ramas et
de la propagande mais mais c'est aussi
ce que vous nous avez dit c'estàd que
l'armée israélienne ne dit pas tout non
plus parce que au fur et à mesure de sa
progression elle a quoi elle a découvert
des corps des dizaines de corps c'est ça
en particulier dans la parti nord de la
bande de Gaza ou l'armée israélienne
essaie d'en prendre le contrôle total
aujourd'hui elle en contrôle à peu près
40 % ce qui pose d'ailleurs question
pour la suite parce que ce que ça aurait
du sens qu'elle se retire s'il y avait
un cessé le feu définitif alors que son
but c'était de contrô complètement cette
zone mais dans les 40 % qu'il contrôlent
aujourd'hui en particulier dans les
tunnels qui ont été très durement
bombardés ils ont retrouvé de nombreux
corps décédés je vous laisse imaginer
que c'est terriblement difficile
d'identifier en général c'est des
prlement qui permettent de confirmer que
mais il y a plusieurs dizaines d'otages
qui ont été retrouvés morts et donc la
question c'est de savoir comment on met
à jour cette liste alors que le Hamas ne
le sait peut-être même pas mais
pardonnez-moi je je je j'ai pas eu cette
information on en avait déjà parlé lors
d'un d'un autre plateau que l'armée
israélienne aurait retrouvé des corpsms
ce qu'on sait en revanche c'est que
quand l'armée israélienne est arrivée à
l'hôpital alchifa et sous les tunnels il
y a eu effectivement des corps qui ont
été retrouvés ceux de Judith Weiss et de
de la soldate Noa Martiano et que ça a
tout de suite
été publié et annoncé par l'armée
israélienne et que je je je ne comprends
pas pourquoi il y aurait cette volonté
de dissimuler les otages morts alors que
dans cas précis ça avait été tout de
suite communiqué à l'ensemble de de
l'opinion publique israélienne alors sur
le nombre d'otage déjà libéré Jonathan
donnait dans son sujet 81 il y a eu deux
otages russes on a appris ça aussi
aujourd'hui donc on serait à 83 60
otages israéliens 23 otages étrangers en
majorité des Thaïlandais et et donc en
contrepartie 180 détenus palestiniens
qui ont été libéré le Premier ministre
Benjamin netanou ça fait partie des
déclarations de de ce mercredi il
confirme il l'avait déjà dit auparavant
que les combats reprendront juste après
la
trêve ces derniers jours on m'a posé une
question après avoir achevé la prise en
charge de nos otages est-ce qu'Israël va
reprendre les combats ma réponse est oui
sans équivoque il n'y a pas
d'arrangement nous reprendrons les
combats jusqu'au
bout c'est ma politique mon cabinet de
sécurité y adhère et l'ensemble du
gouvernement aussi les soldats
soutiennent cette politique le peuple
derrière nous et c'est pour ça que nous
agirons en ce
sens Unis Bage il y a une dimension
géopolitique aussi qui est la pression
américaine que que tente d'obtenir la
diplomatie américaine de Benyamine
netanahou dans l'éventualité d'une
reprise des combats des combats sous une
autre
forme ou alors une trêve qui se prolonge
le plus longtemps possible qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait aujourd'hui alors qu'il
est ce qu'on en sait c'est que le
président américain essaie de faire en
sorte que cette trêve se poursuive au
moins déjà de de quelques jours jour
pour permettre la libération de plus
d'otages notamment la libération de tous
les otages américains ce serait un
succès une avancée pour les États-Unis
et et et pousse aussi pour que cette
trêve se poursuive en en arrêt prolongé
des combats c'est un c'est un c'est un
jeu intéressant entre entre Israël et
les États-Unis car on sait par ailleurs
que les États-Unis soutiennent très
fermment ils l'ont répété à plusieurs
reprises Israël dans cet objectif de
guerre qui est l'éradication du ramas en
tout cas la neutral de sa capacité de
nuisance donc je pense que tout va se
jouer aussi
dans ce qu'on sait des objectifs
atteints par l'armée israélienne
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en coûterait pour
Israël demain de poursuivre ses
objectifs qu'est-ce qui reste à faire
aujourd'hui pour neutraliser cette
menace et qu'est-ce que les Américains
vont demander à
Israël en contrepartie héonorveille une
guerre sous une autre forme ça pourrait
être quoi aujourd'hui ce que demandent
les Américains à Israël d'ailleurs les
les améri Américains et les Israéliens
semblent avoir des intérêts
contradictoires puisque benamin
netanahou et son cabinet de sécurité
Contin continuent à dire chaque jour que
la guerre reprendra dès la fin de ce
cesser le feu et de manière forte et et
et jusqu'au bout et que les États-Unis
espèrent utiliser cette trêve en tout
cas cette période de de de oui de calme
de trêve ou de cesser le feu pour
changer l'aspect de de cette guerre et
la peur aujourd'hui de de de Washington
c'est que les combats ce concentre cette
deuxème phase de la guerre se concentre
dans le sud de la bande de Gaza là où je
vous rappelle que des millions de
Palestiniens on on fuit le nord pour se
rendre dans le sud et là vous allez
sûrement être d'accord avec moi la la la
campagne militaire israélienne sera
encore plus compliquée avec une
population encore encore plus
surabondante et la peur de perdre civil
supplémentaire donc là Washington va
peut-être mettre son véau et d'ailleurs
Joe Biden a déclaré pas plus tard
qu'hier que ça pourrait reprendre cette
campagne militaire mais qu'il faudrait
éviter à tout prix un nouveau
déplacement des populations civiles
palestiniennes donc israël va se
retrouver face au mur et et va devoir
faire des choix face à à son allié de de
toujours améri il y a trois temporalités
différentes la première si on est
logique avec l'opération militaire qui a
été lancée je rappelle qu'elle a été
décidée par le gouvernement néalien ou
bien sû c'est pas de Salal qui décide de
ses opérations ce serait d'aller
jusqu'au bout du contrôle de la partie
nord de la bande de Gaza or actuellement
je rappelle que l'armée israélienne ce
matin on contrôlé un peu plus de 40 %
pas plus donc s'il reprenaient leur
offensive ce serait bien sûr déétendre
totalement leur contrôle ne serait-ce
que pour se dire on n'est pas passé à
côté quelque chose d'important parce
qu'on nous a demandé de nous retirer
très vite la deuxième temporalité ça au
sol ça nécessite à mon avis plusieurs
semaines sans doute deux à tro semaines
on sera déjà mi-décembre et là ensuite
la question c'est une fois qu'on a la
partie nord la bande de Gaza qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de la partie sud est-ce qu'on
sait on essaie de mener des raides mais
dans une population qui est
incroyablement pardon concentrée et là
on sait que c'est un carnage si on veut
mener une opération terrestre ou est-ce
qu'on accepte qu'une grande partie du
Hamas des miliciens du Hamas se soi
échappés dans le sud et que quelque part
ils soi hors de porté ou alors l'armée
israélienne peut aussi pardon pas
l'armée israélienne le gouvernement
netanahou décider que cette partie nord
une fois qu'elle a été quasiment
détruite devient un espèce de nansland
dans lequel il ne laisse pas les
Palestiniens se réinstaller en disant on
veut une zone de sécurité une zone
tampon troisième solution ils sortent de
la partie nord mais à ce momentlà ils
peuvent pas prendre le risque le Hamas
reprennent le contrôle de la bande de
Gaza sinon franchement c'était pas la
peine de faire ça et donc là se poserait
la question de c'est quoi l'autorité
internationale une autorité temporaire
provisoire pas l'ONU parce qu'on connaît
son inefficacité on l'a mesuré ne
serait-ce qu'avec la finule mais une
autorité provisoire mené par quelques
pays qui dit moi je m'assure que en
attendant qu'il y ait une véritable
Autorité palestinienne qui qui émerge
c'est en discussion ça déjà bah c'est
déjà dans des plans qui sont chez Joseph
Borel pour l'Union européenne et en
particulier chez les Américains qui
disent il faut qu'on ait une autorité
provisoire qui permet de reconstruire la
bande de Gaza sans qu'il y ait aucune
possibilité d'agression contre Israël et
ça ça nécessite un pouvoir fort qui va
maîtriser ce qui se passe et on sait que
notamment l'Égypte est assez intéressé
d'avoir une comment dire une vision très
rapprochée ne serait-ce que pour que les
Frères musulmans ne réapparaissent pas
dans un paysage voisin je rappelle que
les Israéliens refusent catégoriquement
l' que l'Autorité palestinienne prenne
le contrôle aujourd'hui en tout cas de
la bande de G je parlais d'une Autorité
palestinienne pas de celle-ci C d'cord
et làdessus juste pour revenir sur ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui dans les
négociations avec les États-Unis Israël
je crois qu'on peut pas en parler aussi
sans parler du rôle du Qatar qui
aujourd'hui joue ce rôle dans la
négociation des otages mais il y a quand
même une grande question qui va se poser
ensuite qui doit déjà se poser dans ce
qui est négocié dans cet accord c'est
quel rôle voudra jouer le Qatar est-ce
qu'il
voudra continuer à défendre les les
intérêts du ramas ou ceux des
Palestiniens est-ce que le le Qatar
aujourd'hui est capable de faire
pression sur le ramas pour obtenir des
garanties de sécurité pour Israël
également qui permettrait une
acceptation d'une trêve plus longue qui
permettrait de se mettre d'accord sur
sur des opérations enfin sur une
poursuite de cette situation différente
qu'une simple reprise de l'opération
militaire par par Israël le catar
évidemment qui est à la manœuvre mais
guillaumeel on parlait des deux Russes
qui ont été libérés aujourd'hui là c'est
un autre
c'est un autre canal en quelque sorte de
discusion nég a deux négociations
parallèles qui ont été menées c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
israélien en a peu parler parce qu'elle
estime que c'était quelque part c'est
pas elle qui a négocié ça les
Thaïlandais ont négocié directement avec
l'Iran en se s'appuyant beaucoup sur la
Malaisie qui je le rappelle est le plus
grand pays musulman du monde et et par
conséquent ils ont un lien particulier
avec l'Iran et Israël a dit moi je si
vous menez une négociation à part je
pardon mais je je m'inscris totalement à
l'écart c'est pour ça qu' ils sont pas
pas dans les décomptes et c'est vrai que
ça a été un peu surprenant ça n'a pas
été critiqué c'est très bien que ces
otages soient libérés c'est des otages
libérés et puis les Russes ont un lien
particulier avec le Hamas on se souvient
qu'il y a un an le ministre des Affaires
étrangères de Poutine lavov était venu
visiter les dirigeants du Hamas on s'est
tous demandé à l'époque ce qu'il venaent
discuter avec le Hamas et je pense que
les Russes ont une implication dans
cette affaire qui est beaucoup plus
grande qu'elle ne laiss s'afficher
jusqu'ici récemment une délégation du
ramas qui est qui est qui est venu qui
qui s'est rendu à Moscou et je vous
rappelle que le premier homme qui a été
libéré dans C dans cette première salve
de libération d'otage c'était un russe à
la demande spécifique de Vladimir
Poutine donc c'est c'est ça ça montre à
quel point Vladimir Poutine a un poids
dans cette dans ces négociations alors
j'ouvre un autre chapitre parce que vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure on reste
évidemment sur le sort des des otages
mais l'une des information de ce
mercredi après-midi c'est cette annonce
du ramas qui annonce la mort de trois
otages un bébé son frère et sa mère et
la nveille je reste avec vous c'est
cette famille dont le sort a été
particulièrement médiatisé les Bibas
pourquoi sont-ils devenus l'un des
symbole des massacres du 7 octobre bah
tout simplement parce qu'il s'agit d'un
d'un bébé qui avait 9 mois qui en a
maintenant 10 et d'un petit garçon de de
de 4 ans et de leur maman on a vu ces
images terribles parmi d'autres images
he qui ont circulé depuis le le 7
octobre de cette mère affolée qui tient
ses enfants et qui sont pris par les
terroristes du ramas dans la bande de
Gaza donc c'est leur c'est le plus jeune
otage d'abord ce ce ce petit Kfir Bibas
et c'est vrai que les les Israéliens
retiennent leur souffle depuis l'annonce
de cet accord d'otage chaque jour je
peux vous dire qu'ils sont tous à se
demander est-ce que les deux petits rou
sont dans la liste des des des personnes
libérées et chaque jour c'est une
déception le le cousin de ils sont ils
sont rou c'est ça avec il y avait des
ballons orange qui symbolisa symbol le
leort tout à fait il y a le le le le
cousin de la famille donc de de la mère
Chéry Bibas qui s'est exprimé de
nombreuses fois notamment sur la chaîne
12 et qui disait que il vivait un
supplice évidemment que c'était comme La
Liste de Schindler si vous voulez tous
les jours ils reçoivent des listes ils
espèrent que le le le les noms de leur
famillees figurent sur ces listes et
chaque jour ils sont déçus alors cette
annonce du ramas il faut la prendre
quand même avec des pincettes parce que
je rappelle que une autre otage Rana
katsir voilà avait été annoncé morte par
par le Jihad islamique et qu'elle a été
libérée il y a quelques jours donc voilà
encore une fois c'est c'est c'est
extrême prudence et et à l'heure où où
on enregistre l'émission où on vous
parle en cette fin d'après-midi on n'a
pas encore de confirmation de la part de
de l'armée israélienne qui qui cherche à
à confirmer c'est évidemment la la
question de la responsabil si personne
ne le souhait mais si ces décès sont
confirmés je vais vous poser la même
question à à l'une et à l'autre va y
avoir un un un bras de faire macabre
pour se rejeter la responsabilité de la
de la de la mort de cette familleel ça
c'est clair Hamas dit c'est les
bombardements israéliens et on verra ce
que Israël dit ce sera le cas pour pour
tous les otages qui n'auront pas été
récupérer de toute façon le Hamas dira
qu'ils ont été tués à cause des
bombardements israéliens et les
Israéliens diront en tout cas le
gouvernement netanahou oui mais c'est
grâce à notre offensive qu'on a pu
libérer d'autres otages là où à mon avis
le gouvernement netanahou n'est pas net
c'est que c'est pas à cause de son
offensive qui libère des otages c'est à
cause de la pression de la société
israélienne qui est
extraordinairement pour qui la vie est
d'une préciosité incroyable c'est pas le
cas du Hamas et qui dit un otage c'est
sacré et donc vous n'avez pas le droit
de sacrifier les otages et puis la
pression des Américains qui veulent
sortir de ce tunnel qui est la guerre
parce que les américains ils ont le
sentiment que la guerre que mène
actuellement le gouvernement netaniaahù
est une impasse dans la mesure où les
patrons du Hamas de toute façon ils sont
au Qatar et que ce qu'on estimait être
les forces du Hamas que que personne ne
sait quantifié elles se sont enfuies
vers le sud et par conséquent on est en
train de taper dans le vide on l'a bien
vu avec le sketch de l'hôpital alchifa
on avait annoncé le quartier général
stratégique du Hamas et malheureusement
on a trouvé que des tunnels pour
l'essentiel vide h Anne Sophie bcage
votre avis sur ce c'est ce qui va se
jouer là dans les prochains jours encore
une fois ESP ça n'est pas confirmé
espérons
que il n'y aura pas de confirmation du
décès de cette famille mais voilà le va
y avoir va y avoir une guerre de
communication là aussi oui bien sûr elle
existe déjà cette guerre de
communication on a vu comment le ramas
orchestre la libération des premiers
otages tous les jours en leur demandant
de de les saluer en essayant de moner
qu'est-ce qu'il pourrait on va en parler
un peu plus tard de ça par nous
interrome qu'est-ce qui pourrait
permettre de d'affirmer avec certitude
qui est responsable ou non de la mort de
cette famille excusez-moi mais à partir
du moment on responsable c'est ceux qui
les ont enlevé bah voilà je ve dire
cette question n'a pas lieu d'être pard
mais je suis d'accord avec vous mais
mais je comprends cette question parce
pose elle est légitime mais mais
qu'est-ce que un ENF Mo bien sûr mais si
c'est un bombardement dans un un
bombardement Isra pas la même chose ça
change qu'est-ce que ça change et c'est
ce que disait la famille la famille de
ses enfants elle disait mais c'est le
ramas qui les a kidnapper c'est le ramas
qui est responsable de les ramener en
vie
et le voilà rentrer dans dans dans ces
considérations est-ce qu'ils sont morts
euh pendant leur captivité ou à cause
des bombes israéliennes finalement c'est
vraiment ne pas voir le problème qui est
qu'un enfant de 10 mois et un enfant de
4 ans n'ont rien à faire ça personne ne
pourra dire le contraire t de cette fa
voilà il faut il faut recentrer le débat
sur ça et que si s'avè après que c'est
des frappes israéliennes ce sera
évidemment terrible mais les
responsables si jamais cette famille
avait péri c'est le Hamas ou et le FPLP
et le Djihad islamique et oui encore une
fois pourquoi ces bombardements aussi
enfin je veux dire ces bombardements
malheureusement sont une réponse à
l'attaque du ramas du du 7 octobre et
quand on voit aussi les pertes de de
soldats israéliens on on oublie souvent
de de le de le préciser mais ces soldats
et ces familles qui doivent renvoyer
leurs enfants à
l'armée vivent aussi un un drame
humain j'ai jamais sur ce plateau
sous-estimé ce que pouvait être l'impact
de des massaces terroristes du 7 octobre
sur la société Israël est-ce que ça
représentait est-ce qu' était la
responsabilité du Hamas évidemment mais
il y a quand même aussi une question sur
la stratégie gu mansel de benjamine
netanahou du cabinet de guerre sur cet
objectif d'éradiquer le ramasse enfin
bon je je suis pas le seul à le dire
beaucoup de spécialistes l'ont dit sur
ce plateau il est quasiment
inatteignable donc jusqu'à quand on va
bombarder pour un objectif qui est sans
doute stratégiquement inatteignable ce
qui est extrêmement gênant c'est que
tout ça ressemble à un incroyable piège
tendu par le Hamas parce que dans son
attaque bestiale du 7 octobre qui
n'était absolument pas justifié ils
avaient aucune raison de massacrer comme
ça les gens on réalise bien que ce qu'il
voulait c'était provoquer une réaction
disproportionnée du gouvernement aen et
aujourd'hui on a une espèce d'inversion
de situation on a l'impression que c'est
quasiment le Hamas qui a la
bienveillance et l'humanité de rendre
quelques otages je rappelle que faire
les otages c'est un crime de guerre les
massacres du 7 octobre je pense que
maintenant tout le monde les connaît 12
morts une sauvagerie inouie ils ont fait
ça pour emmener Israël là où il le
souhaitait et ce qui est terrible dans
la réponse de netanahou c'est qu'il a
jamais de stratégie élaborée il dit
d'une main je veux détruire le Hamas
mais et de l'autre on a l'impression
qu'il a fait le lit du Hamas regardez de
qui on parle aujourd'hui du Hamas on a
l'impression que la Palestine la bande
de Gaza c'est le Hamas pour moi c'est
une erreur stratégique d'autant que les
buts de guerre
d'éradiquer un mouvement terroriste tous
les pays qui ont été confrontés à des
mouvements terroristes le savent la
solution militaire n'est pas complète
bien sûr qu'il faut lutter contre mais
c'est pas en envoyant des chars mercavin
qu'on va détruire le Hamas l'armée du
Hamas et d'ailleurs l'armée israélienne
le dit très bien pour l'instant le Hamas
fait extrêmement attention de pas se
battre contre sal elle serait écrasée
immédiatement donc elle
s'évapore unot un mot quand même un mot
quand même là-dessus parce que c'est pas
uniqueement je dire n'importe quel autre
Premier ministre d'Israël là
effectivement c'est le gouvernement
netanahou et on sait ce qu'on sait de ce
gouvernement et il y a quand même eu un
gouvernement d'union nationale dans dans
la crise c'est plus le même gouvernement
qui qui qui était là avant le 7 octobre
mais n'importe quel autre Premier
ministre d'Israël aurait rosté
militairement face à cette at je suis
d'accord avec vous que c'est que la la
réponse militaire ne peut jamais être la
seule réponse et qu'on peut pas venir au
bout qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
éradiquer le ramas de toute façon
l'idéologie on l'éradiquera pas
maintenant faire en sorte que pour au
moins quelques années pour au moins une
décennie les populations du sud d'Israël
soient en sécurité que le Hamas ne
puisse pas se réarmer réengager une
offensive c'est déjà un objectif qui est
atteignable je veux dire on on verra
dans les mois qui viennent dans les
semaines qui viennent ce qui se passe
mais seul une opération militaire permet
de neutraliser au moins disait Joe Biden
ne refaites pas les erreurs qu'on a
commises après non bien sûr je dire face
à daesh par exemple la coalition
internationale est-ce qu'elle a
totalement éradiqué daesh elle a elle a
fortement réduit sa capacité de nuisance
sa capacité de projection de de
d'organiser des attaques est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
de combattants DAEs il n'y a plus de de
terroristes qui se réclam de cette
organisation et de cette idéologie non
mais quel enfin quelle autre réponse
pouvait-on envisager face à l'attaque du
7 octobre je vous pose la question et je
nous pose la question collectivement
Mathieu et pour prolonger la question de
Thomas est-ce que en fait le le le but
de guerre é radiquer le Hamas c'était
compatible avec exiger et retrouver la
libération de tous les otages oui je
crois que c'est un c'est un double
objectif il ne pouvait que roster
militairement et engager dès le départ
comme ça a été fait des négociations
pour pour la libération mais c'est une
bonne question non mais bien sûr que
c'est une bonne question mais quelle op
quelle autre option était possible non
je je Mo je vais vous parler uniquement
d'un point de vue militaire il se trouve
que j'ai conduit des opérations
d'extraction on a un choix très dur à
faire à ce moment-là soit on lance une
offensive contre ceux qui détiennent les
otages soit on va récupérer les otages
mais c'est pas la même chose et quand le
gouvernement Netanyahou a pris ce choix
de lancer une offensive terrestre très
dure très très violente contre la bande
de Gaza il savait que les otages
seraient passeraiit dessous et
d'ailleurs le fait qu'il plusieurs
dizaines d'otages je vous dis sans doute
à peu près le nombre des d'otage qui
vont être échangés ça montre bien que
malheureusement en prenant cette option
là ils savaient qu'il sacrifi un certain
nom d'otage et ce qui est étonnant c'est
que maintenant il essaie de vendre à
tout le monde que c'est grâce à son
offensive qu'il permet de libérer les
otages alors que c'est pas grâce à son
offensive c'est parce que la société
israélienne a exigé une trève il le
voulait pas forment ça arrange aussi le
khamas je veux dire le khamas a quand
même été affaibli et a besoin
aujourd'hui de jours de trêve pour se
réorganiser pour se réarmer pour se
déplacer pourquoi pourquoi pourqu est-ce
que le ramas a pris des otages sinon
pour pour prendre en otage Israël et
pour se donner une une une porte de
sortie une possibilité un moment de de
se réarmer de se
réorganis je je pense que c'est
important de d'essayer de comprendre
aussi quelle est c'est difficile à dire
mais quelle est la la stratégie du ramas
si en effet ce n'est pas les taux qui se
resserraient autour de de de de ces de
cette branche militaire qui a permis la
libération de et je ne suis pas experte
militaire donc je je ne le sais pas ce
qui a fait que y noir a accepté cet
accord ce deal et ce cesser le feu
est-ce que le cesser le feu c'était pas
justement un besoin pour le Hamas de se
réarmer de souffler de et ça voudrait
dire que les taux se resserraient autour
du ramas donc où est d'un point de vue
militaire seulement comment on explique
que ils ont accepté cet
accord et à quel point le les
prisonniers Palestiniens étaient un un
point important aussi dans la stratégie
du Hamas le Hamas pour moi attendait
patiemment que à cause de la pression
interne et externe notamment des
États-Unis mais aussi des égyptien il
soit mis comme interlocuteur comme un
acteur étatique incontournable qui
aujourd'hui est vu par le monde entier
comme étant le seul interlocuteur viable
de la bande Gaza c'est exactement ce que
cherchait le Hamas qui l'a dit dans une
déclaration New York Times il y a 3
semaines qui a dit 1 on veut installer
un état de guerre permanent avec Israël
exactement ce qu'a fait Israël et
deuxièmement on veut montrer que c'est
nous la représente
quand on lit les derniers sondages
enjordanie Leamas est en tête des
sondages il est maintenant oui alors on
va continuer de de parler de du sort des
des otages et peut-être de leur
condition de détention je vous propose
d'abord un témoignage celui de
O dan proche de deux adolescents qui ont
été libérés mais sans nouvelle de leur
père de nos enfants bienaimés s 16 ans
et Rs 12 ans viennent d'être libérés par
le Hamas et ont atterri sur le toit de
cet hôpital avec l'hélicoptère de
l'armée nous sommes pleins de joie de
bonheur mais en même temps nous sommes
trè qui pour leur père mon cousin offer
Calderon qui est toujours en
captivité j'accueille audre V sur ce
plateau bonsoir audre donc grâce à ces
témoignage des proches des otages eux-
mêmees on commence à en savoir un petit
peu plus sur leurs conditions de de
détention oui même si les autorités
israéliennes appellent à la plus grande
discrétion sur ces conditions les otages
ont d'ailleurs été briffés avant de
pouvoir retrouver leur famillees des
bribes d'informations nous proviennent
on découvre que ces conditions de
détention étaient bien différentes selon
les otages certains étaient retenus dans
des tunnels sans pouvoir voir la lumière
et ceux pendant 50 jours de très longues
journées des nuits à dormir assis sur
des chaises les uns contre les autres
comme dans dans une salle d'attente
parfois il fallait attendre près d'une
heure et3 pour pouvoir aller aux
toilettes une hygiène précaire même si
les ravisseurs faisaient leur maximum
pour éviter les maladies c'est ce qu' a
rapporté une exotage qui a été libérée
après 2 semaines de
captivité ils se sont assuré que nous
avions tout ce qu'il fallait que les
toilettes étaient propres pour que nous
ne tombions pas malades ils avaient peur
de la
peste évidemment leurs conditions de
détention ont empiré au fur à mesure que
les jours passaient notamment en matière
de nourriture les otages expliquent
qu'il mangeaient au début un peu comme
leur ravisseurs des pitas du fromage
frais des concombres au fur et à mesure
les rations ont commencé à s'amenuiser
un peu de riz un peu de pain de manière
très irrégulière parfois pas tous les
jours comme l'explique une responsable
d'un service d'urgence qui a pris en
charge ses
aotages les personnes qui arrivent ont
perdu beaucoup de poids en très peu de
temps moins 10 % de leur masse voire
plus ce qui constitue un problème
médical elles ont été nourres avec des
aliments très peu nutritifs et qu'en
est-il des enfants et bien on en sait un
peu plus grâce au témoignage de la
famille d'an ce Français de 12 ans qui
vient d'être libéré on découvre que les
enfants n'avaient le droit de jouer qu'
carartes ou de dessiner interdiction de
parler à voix haute sous peine d'être
tué en tout cas c'est les menaces qu'ils
entendaient une emprise psychologique
qui dure encore maintenant au moment où
les enfants ont été rendus à leur
famille certains ne s'exprimaient qu'en
chuchaotant alors évidemment ça pose la
question maintenant du choc
psychologique pour ces enfants qui ont
été en captivité pendant de très longues
semaines merci beaucoup Audrey on va
continuer de parler de peut-être on l'a
évoqué rapidement et je me tourne vers
vous Mathieu de la de la guerre de
communication de la guerre des des
images en quelque sorte il y a il y a
ces images de libération d'otage depuis
depuis quelques jours comment sont-elles
mises en scène qu'est-ce moi ce qui me
frappe déjà sur l'échelle du conflit
c'estàdire depuis le 7 octobre c'est
qu'on a jamais eu autant d'images elles
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreus d'une
certaine façon elles n'ont jamais autant
prêté à caution elles n'ont jamais été
aussi contrôlé et puis n'ont peut-être
jamais été autant mis en scène et ça on
retrouve dans les trois séquences du
conflit d'abord dans le fait générateur
avec le Hamas qui filme les atrocités
terroristes qu'il commet le 7 octobre
donc c'est quand même assez inédit dans
l'histoire que que des criminels de
guerre des terroristes enfin les
terroristes il en avaient déjà eu mais
que que dans ce type de conflit on filme
des atrocités d'habitude les agresseurs
les plan dis ben non c'est pas nous on a
jamais fait ça là il les filme pour les
terroriser ensuite on passe dans la PHAs
de ripost israélienne et là le Hamas ne
cherche plus à terroriser il cherche à
émouvoir et on a toutes les images qu'on
a vu après les bombardements de père
avec des enfants dans les bras et puis
là il le cherche il utilis les images
aujourd'hui pour triompher dans cette
période de cesser le feu en montrant le
le Hamas bienveillant avec les otages à
qui on demande continue de faire coucou
s'il te plaît et puis enfin des des
trucs absolument délirants et puis le
retour des des prisonniers palestiniens
donc il est à la fois triomphant sur son
territoire libérateur voilà et en face
Isra dans ces trois phases a toujours
été sur la défensive dans la première
celle du fait générateur elle va
réutiliser les images du Hamas pour
dénoncer c'est pour que les gens dans la
communauté internationale croisent ce
qui s'est passé et réalisent ce qui
s'est passé dans la seconde partie
c'estàd celle de laarost tandis que le
Hamas cherche mouvoir israël va chercher
à se justifier et ça donne ces images un
peu délirantes qu'on a vu à l'hôpital
d'alchifa où ils sont obligés d'aligner
trois kalashnikov et des choses qu'ils
ont trouvé pour prouver que ils sont
dans leur bon droit de de de reposter et
là dans cette dernière phase ben eux y a
évidemment toutes les émotions qu'on
voit dans dans les rassemblements de
famille en Israël mais je trouve que
c'est incroyable que que que cette
inversion comme ça de de de de
l'utilisation des images dont le Hamas
sort vainqueur il faut le dire en tout
cas jusque jusqu'à présent et juste pour
finir je trouve qu'on a de plus en plus
d'images mais d'une certaine façon de
moins en moins d'éducation à l'image
parce que l'opinion publique
internationale est saisi abreué sur les
réseaux sociaux toutes ces images qui
circulent plus personne n'est capable de
les contextualiser plus personne n'est
capable de les comprendre parce queavant
on on on on ne croit que ce que l'on
voit ça c'était avant comme comme saint
Thomas aujourd'hui on ne voit que ce que
l'on croit et donc même quand vous avez
des images qui vous arrivent en pleine
figure vous dit bah non ça NAA pas
existé c'est pas ça jusqu'à pour finir
puisqu'on en parle sur ce plateau ces
visages d'otage qui sont tellement
dérangeants pour certains qui ne veulent
tellement pas y croire qu'ils se
précipitent pour les arracher dès qu'il
les voi afficher merci Mathieu je
voudrais qu'on parle des Palestiniens
qui ont été libérés par Isral
en
contrepartie de de la libération des
otages donc des détenus palestiniens je
vous propose un témoignage un homme son
fils de 14 ans était le plus jeune des
tenu palestinien
écoutez parorsque Ahmed était en prison
nous ne pouvions pas lui rendre visite
bien qu'il soit le plus jeune prisonnier
palestinien lorsque la guerre a commencé
le 7 octobre nous avons perdu tout
contact avec notre
fils que sait-on Guillaume mansel des
des otages enfin pardon le lapsus je
m'en excuse des détenus palestiniens qui
ont été libérés par Israël alors en fait
Israël rend beaucoup de prisonniers en
échange des otages hein dans un ratio de
3 pour un qui est pas tout à fait exact
parce qu'en fait le Hamas a libéré un
peu plus à cause de ce qu'on a dit tout
à l'heure sur les Thaïlandais et les
Russes mais ce sont des prisonniers sans
importance pardon mais il y a absolument
aucun aucune figure de prou
palestinienne à l'intérieur ce sont des
gens qui en fait condition mis par
Israël pour tout à fait ce sont des gens
qui sont en attente de jugement parce
que ils ont commis des délits ou euh des
des crimes mais pas des crimes de sang
depuis le 7 octobre et que en fait ils
étaient emprisonnés en attente d'être
jugés et en fait pardon mais Israël s'en
débarrasse un peu parce que de toute
façon c'est pas des gens qui auraient
passé des années en prison et ils n'ont
pas de poids dans l'évolution de la
situation politique on ne parle pas de
bargouti on ne parle pas des leaders
palestiniens qui sont en prison et que
pour moi aurait beaucoup plus de sens de
négocier sauf que à mon avis le Hamas
tient pas tellement à les récupérer bien
sûr on a aucun intérêt à les faire
libérer surtout surtout bargouti pardon
Marwan bargouti qui est emprisonné
depuis plus de 20 ans et qui était
effectivement l'un des leaders
palestiniens Ann Sophie c'est
bambéache il faut peut-être revenir un
peu en arrière là aussi la libération de
du soldat Guil Chalit alors là c'était
contre un millier de de de détenus
palestiniens quel leçon Israël
tire-t-elle de ce qui s'était passé à
l'époque sur l'identité de de de de
celles et ceux qui avaient été sortis
des prison israélienne ce qui s'était
passé à l'époque est ce qui a beaucoup
ému l'opinion publique israélienne c'est
que parmi ces 1000 prisonniers
palestiniens il y a en effet le
commanditaire principal de l'attaque du
du 7 octobre et ce qui est ce qui est un
élément qui qui me
semblait n permettre de dire que le
ramas a quand même été affaibli c'est
effectivement le ratio qui a quand même
changé
dans le nombre de Palestiniens de de
détenus palestiniens libérés en échange
des otages et et ça a été effectivement
pour le soldat gilash un prix très lourd
à payer pour Israël mais qu'Israël était
prêt à payer que la société israëlne
était prête à payer pour sauver pour
sauver cette vie et qui serait qui qui
est toujours prête à le faire on m'a
posé la question de est-ce qu'il y a un
changement une évolution dans la
stratégie sur la libération des otages
je je crois pas je crois que à chaque
fois malheureusement Israël est dans une
situation comme vous l'avez décrite très
compliqué son les pièges tendus par ces
organisations terroristes mais la
volonté de de tout faire pour pour les
libérer jusqu'à libérer voilà jusqu'à
libérer des des il y a des soldats dans
lesages oui est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
que le ratio change quand il s'agira de
libérer les soldats alors c'est
justement le le c'était le le sujet des
discussions de la Réunion qu partite qui
a qui a qui a eu lieu hier à DOA entre
les chefs de renseignement américains
que égyptien médiateur Catari et le chef
du mossade euh on parle de cinq
catégories hein de de d'otage les femmes
et les enfants les hommes les hommes les
soldats actifs et les les les personnes
âgées et les corps des soldats parant
c'est C cinq catégories en tout et il
est question aujourd'hui ça fait partie
des discussions d'une future libération
d'hommes en âge d'être soldat donc de
potentiel réserviste et de soldats il y
a aucune confirmation aujourd'hui sur un
accord potentiel de libérer des soldats
mais ça fait partie aujourd'hui des
négociations est-ce que le nombre de
détenus palestiniens pourrait changer
mais mais voilà comme on disait le ramas
n'a pas forcément intérêt à libérer tous
les prisonniers palestiniens puisque
certains prisonniers palestiniens sont
des figures emblématiques de l'Autorité
palestinienne qu'il pourrai euh sil
s'ils étaient libérés s'il revenaient en
sisjordanie euh avoir une certaine
légitimité un certain pouvoir et du coup
voler un peu le le la vedette du ramas
donc ça aussi ça ça va faire partie de
des négociations de ces prochains jours
qui qui est à la manœuvre qui sera à la
manœuvre dans les prochains jours
imaginons que cette trêve se prolonge
est-ce que ça peut se transformer en une
négociation plus vaste plus large al le
le le point sémantique c'est que on fait
souvent on oppose trêve à cesser le feu
alors que ça veut dire la même chose
mais sauf que dans notre esprit et c'est
normal c'est un usage la trêve c'est
temporaire un cesser le feu c'est
l'amorce d'une sortie du de la guerre et
ce que veulent les Américains très
clairement c'est qu'on sorte de la
guerre pour deux raisons la première
c'est que ils n'ont aucune confiance
dans les buts de guerre qui ont été
affichés par netaniaou ils pensent ils
ont quand même pas mal d'expérience sur
le sujet notamment les talibans qui sont
allés chercher en Afghanistan qui été
une vraie catastrophe que de toute façon
ils sont inatteignables et donc ils
disent plus vite on sera sorti de ça
mieux ce sera et la deuxième chose c'est
que on se rapproche des élections
présidentiel aux États-Unis et qu'il y a
une partie de la société américaine qui
dit attendez nous on a toujours défendu
Israël mais pas les carnages qui sont en
train d'être commis dans la bande de
Gaza et par conséquent ça ce n'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça pourquoi
parce que le Hamas a créé de la part du
gouvernement netanahou une confusion
entre le Hamas et les Palestiniens de la
bande de c'est exactement ce que voulait
le Hamas et c'est de là d'où veulent
sortir les Américains qui ne veulent
plus voir ces images on en parlait tout
à l'heure absolument atrocce d'hôpitaux
dans de de de m avec leur enfant qui a
été tué donc on voit bien que les
Américains veulent S
et pour eux sortir c'est une fois qu'on
aura goûté au cesser le feu c'est
arriver à apaiser tout le monde et dire
maintenant il faut qu'on trouve un moyen
de sortir de là ce qui est très
difficile Ann Sophie c'est est-ce que
c'est pas de plus en plus difficile de
repartir en guerre si le si cette trêve
dur oui j'ajoute un point je pense sur
les raisons qui qui expliqu pourquoi les
États-Unis ve veulent que ça s'arrête
c'est aussi que si le conflit se
poursuit il y a un risque bien sûr un
risque VO il y a un risque d'escalade
régionale qu'on a réussi à éviter pour
pour le moment grâce notamment à la
force de de dissuasion américaine mais
les intérêts américains ont été menacés
il y a toujours cette menace qui pèse au
nord d'Israël avec le hzbolah il y a
toujours le risque que l'Iran entre dans
le jeu et la reprise des
hostilités ferait durer ce risque on
voit aussi comment l'Arabie Saoudite
essaie de jouer un rôle à offert
aujourd'hui et depuis le 7 octobre à
l'Iran d'ugmenter ses investissements et
sa coopération en échange de de
l'assurance de la part de du régime là
qu'il ne qu'il ne créerait pas
d'escalade et qu'il ne ne déclencherait
pas ses proxis pour pour élargir le
conflit donc il y a vraiment cet aspect
là qui est important à l'approche des
élections sachant que le conflit
ukrainien n'est pas terminé ce serait ce
serait désastreux pour les États-Unis
qu'un autre front s'ouvre merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous dis
à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat c'est
l'ORS du second débat de ce sens public
la COP 28 ouvre ses portes demain à
Dubaï parmi les nombreux défis qui
seront abordés nous avons choisi de
zoomer sur la fonte des des pôles plus
de 28000 tonnes de glace ont disparu
depuis
1994 les conséquences sont nombreuses
pour le climat global de notre planète
pour les animaux évidemment qui vivent
dans dans ces régions mais aussi pour
ceux qui lorgnent sur ces nouvelles
routes commerciale en train de s'ouvrir
avant d'en débattre on fait le constat
de cette fonte de la banquise avec
Cécile Sixou elle est allée rencontrer
notamment Mathieu torder un aventurier
qui alerte sur ce phénomène
voilà Antarctique
sympa non c'était un rêve de gosse en
2018 Matthieu tordur part à l'aventure
50 jours seul pour rallier le Pôle Sud
sans assistance et en totale autonomie
ah là là je suis seul au
monde il s'attend à des températures
glaciales jusqu'à - 30° mais certains
jours il avance dans une neige molle en
T-shirt c'est complètement absurde il
fait beaucoup trop chaud là je comprends
pas cette météo 4 ans plus tard il
raconte son étonnement pendant plusieurs
semaines au début de mon expédition
c'est à ça que je me retrouve confronté
c'està-dire que parfois je tire mon
traîneau juste avec un une polaire quoi
un t-shirt polaire et ça m'a vachement
questionn quoi je je me disais maisf à
quel moment dans ce continent qui est
censé être le continent le plus froid du
monde on peut se permettre de tirer un
traîau juste en T-shirt des
questionnements et une prise de
conscience l'Antarctique change sa vie
Mathieu s'engage ses expéditions se
concentrent désormais sur les pôles et
les glaciers des montagnes à chaque fois
il observe de ses propres yeux la
réduction des banquises glaciers et
calottes polair et n'a désormais qu'une
ambition alert sur cette fond des glaces
et ses conséquences climatiques mon
activité aujourd'hui consiste à faire le
lien un petit peu entre la communauté
scientifique qui alerte avec des
rapports mais moi j'ai pas ce bagage
scientifique je peux juste essayer de
vulgariser ce qui se dit pour le rendre
intelligible auprès du grand public et
ça ça passe justement par des
expéditions par de la sensibilisation
par l'émotion par l'émerveillement par
des documentaires ambassadeur auprès du
grand public Mathieu espère aussi faire
bouger le monde politique il s'inquiète
notamment pour l'article ils font à
vitesse grandv et sera libre de glace en
2050 je crois que on est tous au courant
de ce qui se passe mais finalement des
décisions très courageuses je à mon sens
manque un petit peu parce qu'on sait
tous ce qu' faut faire il faut
absolument arrêter tout projet d'énergie
fossile et et limiter le plus possible
les émissions de CO2 et quand on regarde
un petit peu la courbe des émissions
aujourd'hui qu'elle soit nationale ou
globale on n pas commencé vraiment à
ralentir quoi donc je crois que c'est
lent je crois que c'est difficile je
crois qu'il faut garder espoir parce que
tout n'est pas perdu l'espoir c'est ce
qui le fait avancer si tout va bien
Mathieu devrait retourner cet été en
Arctique pour une expédition envoiliée
au plus près des glaciers
quelles sont les conséquences
climatiques et géopolitiques de la fonte
des glaces polaires on est en débat avec
Françoise Vimeux bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes climatologue directrice de
recherche l'Institut de Recherche pour
le Développement Jean-Louis Étienne
bonsoir et bienvenue médecin explorateur
écrivain créateur de ce projet de
station océanographique polarp et vous
avez préfacé cet ouvrage Grand Nord un
voyage dans le cercle artique publé chez
glena j'accueille Mika blujonmer bonsoir
et bienvenue vous êtes chargé
d'enseignement à science à l'école de
guerre sur la géopolitique des pôles et
des Outremers et vous publiez les mondes
polaires c'est au presses universitaires
de France Mathieu croissandoau
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
Françoise Vimeux cette cette fonte des
des glaces polaires est-ce que c'est
irréversible on est dans quelle
situation là alors oui la la fonte des
des calottes polaires et même des
glaciers de haute montagne c'est
irréversible à l'échelle humaine he bien
sûr parce que on touche à des
composantes qui ont un temps de réponse
très long et donc à partir du moment où
vous faites une petite perturbation de
ces composantes j'ai il y a aussi
l'océan qui réagit très lentement et
bien il y a un temps de réponse qui va
être de plusieurs siècles voire de
plusieurs millénaires et donc la fonte
là que l'on voit la calotte du Groenland
en Antarctique et surtout aussi les
glaciers de haute montagne dont on parle
un peu moins et bien à notre échelle
c'est irréversibleou Jean-Louis ettienne
on peut faire un peu de pédagogie pour
pour commencer les les glaces polaires
c'est est-ce que c'est la même chose en
en Arctique ou en Artic où vous allez
aller avec polarp est-ce que on parle de
banquis dans les deux cas pardon c'est
vraiment une question de bé je préfère
qu'on fasse un peu de pédagogie pour
démarer oui le Pôle Nord le Pôle Sud le
Pôle Nord est au milieu d'un océan un
océan qui est gelé qui gèle tous les
hivers qui est recouvert par de la
banquise et tout autour vous avez des
terres des immenses sibéries le le
Canada hein et qui sont recouverts d'une
de neige une grande partie de l'année
donc ce territoire est blanc hein blanc
parce que la l'océan est gelé avec de la
glace blanche qui réfléchit l' reement
solaire et tout autour le permaapros le
jeli sol le sol jeel permanence et la
majorité du temps blanc et il réfléchit
le rayonement solaire aujourd'hui avec
le rayon avec le
réchauffement
climatique vous avez la surface de la
banquise on le voit tous les ans
septembre septembre octobre qui régresse
et qui libère une zone
foncée voyez il y a plus de sur cet
océan tout corps foncé capte le
rayonnement électromagnétique du soleil
vous faites l'expérience pas pas
maintenant parce qu'il fait nuit vous
mettez la main sur une voiture blanche
elle est à la température ambiante la
noire elle est beaucoup plus chaude
parce que le noir capte donc on assiste
on a on assiste un arti l'Arctique est
touché parce qu'il change de couleur
est-ce que c'est la même chose de
l'autre côté alors ça c'est l'Artique
l'Antarctique en terme de surface c'est
un peu la même chose l'océan Arctique
est grand est aussi grand que le
continent c'est un continent qui est a
sud d'un continent de glace vous mettez
un puzzle comme ça 28 Fran bien serré
vous recouvrez le tout de 2 km de de
glace en moyenne c'est la taille du
glaçon qui a en Antarctique et ce
continent antarctique il est entouré par
un océan qu'on appelle l'océan Austral
donc voyez c'est l'inverse là-haut un
océan entouré de terre en bas un
continent de glace entouré d'océan m on
a un peu répondu mais cette cette fonte
accélérée des glaces elle était
prévisible voir annoncée depuis depuis
longtemps elle était annoncé et
justement elle a fait l'objet d'un
certain nombre de controverses parce
qu'il y a eu des surexagérations par
rapport à cette fondte des glaces on a
dit par exemple dans les à la fin des
années 2000 que l'Arctique allait être
libre de glace intégralement plus du
tout de banquise l'été dès 2012 puis dès
2014 puis dès 2016 et effectivement ça a
généré deux mouvements ça a généré un
mouvement de panique dans une certaine
franche de la population à l'échelle
mondiale panique et une sentiment
d'urgence pour préserver lespaule ok
très bien mais ça a aussi généré un
sentiment complè compl contraire de gens
qui petit à petit ont bien vu en 2012 en
2014 en 2016 que l'Arctique en fait ne
fondait pas en tout cas toute l'année et
se sont dit oh là là mais on nous
raconte vraiment n'importe quoi mais
vraiment ils exagèrent ces écol bobo et
cetera donc ce qui se passe à la fin du
jeu c'est qu'on se retrouve avec une
polarisation du jeu politique sur ces
questions là et qu'à chaque fois l'ours
polaire la banquise l'Antarctique et
cetera sont instrumentalisé par les deux
camp et certains sont plus dans le camp
scientifique que d'autres très
clairement oui ça on peut ça on est bien
d'accord phénomène il s'accélère le taux
de fonte des glaces a augmenté de 65 %
en 30 ans François imimeux est-ce que
cette accélération elle elle elle va
d'une façon exponentielle c'estàd
qu''est-ce que ça s'accélère encore plus
vite depuis 4 5 ans par exemple oui
alors ce qu'on voit déjà on peut donner
he le taux au 20e siècle la montée du
niveau des mers en moyenne c'était 1,5 à
2 mm par an aujourd'hui on est plutôt à
4,5 mm par an donc c'est une
accélération qu'on avait pas forcément
très bien vu venir et anticiper et le
facteur dominant qui contrôle la montée
du niveau des mers aujourd'hui c'est la
fonte des calottes polaires et des
glaciers de montagne alors on ne sait
pas forcément comment ça va évoluer mais
vu comment c'est parti a priori oui ça
va continuer à s'accélérer et les
projections climatiques nous disent que
sur les trajectoires d'émission de gaz à
effet de serre sur lesqueles nous sommes
on aura une élévation de l'ordre de 60
cm à la fin du siècle de manière
inéluctable on aura plus de 1 m voire
plus plusieurs mètres dans les siècles à
venir et là on ne peut rien faire que
s'adapter en fait et et puis pour
l'atténuation de du changement
climatique ça aura un impact mais
vraiment beaucoup plus tardivement
encore une fois ce sont les composantes
lentes de notre système climatique et ça
pose évidemment la la question des
réfugiés climatiques on y reviendra un
peu plus tard dans notre dans notre
débat les les températures constatées à
l'époque contemporaine dans certaines
parties du Groenland sont les plus
chaudes jamais enregistré au cours du
dernier millénaire c'est ce qui explique
ce professeur boslo vinter co-auteur
d'une étude sur ce thème qui qui est
paru dans la revue Nature on l'écoute on
voit vraiment que ces endroits sur la
calotte glaciaire du Groenland se sont
beaucoup réchauffé en fait si l'on
replace ce phénomène dans le contexte du
climat on constate que les carottes de
glace remonte à environ 1000 ans et
qu'elles n'ont jamais été aussi chaudes
au cours des 1000 dernières
années c'est donc la principale
conclusion de cette recherche le signal
de réchauffement planétaire que nous
observons partout dans le monde a
également trouvé son chemin vers
endroits très éloignés de la calotte
glaciare du
Groenland donc ça c'est pour le Pôle
Nord Groenland Jean-Louis Étienne c'est
de l'autre côté on est bien d'accord
c'est au pôle Sud en Antarctique que
vous partez fin 2025 si tout va bien
pour étudier l'océan Austral pourquoi
est-il vital pour notre planète cet
océan austral l'océan Austral qui
entoure le continent antarctique donc
c'est le principal puit de carbone
océanique de la planète à lui seul il
absorbe certainement 50 % du CO2 qui est
remblé par l'ensemble de l'océan mondial
et donc il est loin il est difficile
d'accès on parle là des 50è hurlan hein
c'est c'est très venté les marins du
vent des globes nous en parlent tous les
4 ans des vagues de 20 25 m c'est ça ça
peut monter jus gr déjà quand même quoi
et les missions se font essentiellement
l'été et donc toutes les communications
sur cet océan se terminent on a besoin
de mesurer une situe de longue durée en
Nomo on a besoin de s'installer sur cet
océan dans l'équation c'est quel type de
vaisseau pour s'installer dans des
bonnes conditions de sécurité de confort
sur cette océan de tempête donc vous
avez imaginé un vaisseau vertical c'est
ça bah oui il faut échapper à la surface
c'est là où le le le vent et la mer se
rencomre ça fait des vagues don les
bateaux sont posés à la surface donc ça
bouge si on veut échapper aux vagues il
faut avoir un vaisseau donc c'est un
flotteur vertical qui a 75 m de tir en
d'au donc il est pris dans des eaux
profondes stables à la surface on a un
trayli donc qui est poureux à la vague
et on habite dans une nacelle à une
dizaine de mètres au dessus de l'eau
toutes les maquettes qu'on a pu faire
les études montrent qu'il est très
stable dans la grosse mer ça va
permettre de séjourner et dans et de
faire des mesures tout au long de
l'année c'est ça qui est demandé oui
c'est c'est ça qui est important et
c'est ce que les scientifiques attendent
aussi c'est ça ah ben si vous voulez
dans les modèles climatiques c'est un le
je le répète le principal P de carbone
océanique parce que le CO2 se dissou
beaucoup plus dans les eaux froides
c'est pour ça qu'il est le principal le
CO2 se dissou beaucoup plus dans les
eaux froide que dans les EAU tempérées
et deuxièmement c'est un océan qui
défirere ces vagues sans arrêt en
prisonne de
donc c'est lui qui capte le plus de CO2
donc c'est un régulateur du climat
important François votre avis sur ce
comment on explique effectivement cette
régulation du climat par l'océan Austral
notamment alors en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que on a dans notre système
climatique deux régulateurs qui sont la
circulation atmosphérique et la
circulation océanique et bon l'océan
Austral a une superficie un très large
il a un rôle énorme dans la circulation
océanique et donc dans le captage du
dioxyde de carbone et puis pour pour
rajouter on a ce qu' ce qu'on aurait
vraiment aussi envie de comprendre c'est
quelles sont les interactions entre
l'Océan austral et la calotte
antarctique on a beaucoup d'incertitude
sur comment cette calotte polaire
pourrait se déstabiliser au fur à mesure
que la température augmente il y a des
processus qu'on connaît mal à
l'interface entre l'océan et les
plateformes glacées hein qui empêche la
calotte de glisser trop vite hein si je
peux dire ça comme ça dans l'océan et là
on a vraiment aussi besoin de de
comprendre cette interface océan calot
temp ouis et puis alors puisqu'on parle
de fonte des glaces polaires c'est de
l'eau douce qui qui se diffuse dans un
océan salé avec quelle conséquence alors
c'est c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
qui se passe au pôle ne reste pas
auôulant au-delà du du niveau marin
quand vous faites fond d'une calotte
polaire c'est le niveau marin partout
sur la terre qui augmente vous avez
après un effet de la fonte des calottes
sur la circulation océanique pourquoi
parce que on met de l'eau douce dans
l'eau salée donc en fait on change la
densité de l'eau l'eau de mer devient
moins salé et en fait on a une
circulation océanique qu'on appelle
circulation thermoaline qui par exemple
dans l'océan Atlantique vient de
l'équateur se dirige vers le Groenland
avec l'objectif de répartir la chaleur
dans les océans arrivé au groenlande
cette eau elle se refroidit la banquise
se forme la banquise elle éjecte le sel
donc l'eau est froide et salée elle
plonge et puis elle repart en fait vers
des zones plus chaudes et lorsque des
conséquences sur l'écosystème sur euh ça
c'est un phénomène qui est absolument
naturel he cette circulation à l'échelle
planétaire en revanche avec le
changement climatique comme on ajoute
plus d'eau douce et bien on vient
ralentir cette circulation thermoaline
et donc là on vient modifier les
transports de chaleur dans notre système
climatique et là c'est vraiment des
perturbation à l'échelle globale allez
on va parler de la COP 28 avec vous
Mathieu elle s'ouvre demain à Dubaï on y
parlera aussi de la fonte des glaces
polaire elle est sous le feu des
critiques cette comm oui alors rarement
une conférence des parties sur le
changement climatique puisque c'est le
nom complet n'aura été autant contesté
avant même qu'elle ait commencé alors
pas sur le principe hein non même si on
peut se désoler que il se passe plus
grand-chose dans les cops depuis celle
de la COP 21 de Paris en 2015
n'insultons pas l'avenir peut-être
quelque chose sortira de ce conclave qui
accueille quand même 196 pays du monde
Vatican compris même si le pape François
on l'a pris qui devait faire les
déplacement ne s'y rendra pas pour cause
de grippe non ce qui crispe en fait
c'est d'abord le lieu retenu pour
accueillir cette COP 28 à savoir Dubaï
l'une des Péro arch qui a le pire bilan
carbone par habitant au monde et qui
tente ainsi de s'offrir à bon compte une
vaste opération de Green wasing en
direct sous toutes les caméras de de la
planète alors ça c'est pour le lieu il y
a aussi la personnalité choisie qui pour
présider cette cette COP bah oui le
sultan aljberer ministre de l'Industrie
et PDG d'adnoc la principale compagnie
pétrolière du pays assis sur les 4è
réserve pétrolière mondiale pour le
symbole c'est un peu comme si on
confiait au COB Malboro la présidente de
la Ligue contre le cancer mais il y a
plus embêtant c'est selon une enquête de
la BBC Ahmed aljberber aurait voulu
utiliser son rôle dans cet événement
international pour conclure des marchés
dans les énergies fossiles en juin
dernier le gardien cette fois-ci
révélait que la compagnie pétrolière
adnooc avait pu avoir accès à des email
relatif aux négociations de la COP 28
avait même été consulté sur la stratégie
média bref on âge en plein conflit
d'intérêts on peut même ajouter au
conflitinttérêt le cabinet minse plus
grand cabinet de conseil au monde qui se
serait servi de son influence dans les
préparatives de la COP 28 pour défendre
les intérêts de ses clients pétrogazers
selon une enquête de la FP donc bref
c'est vraiment de quoi irriter indigner
nombre de participants d'observateurs à
commencé par les ONG qui ont malgré tout
décidé de ne pas boycotter les travaux
de cette COP argant que les enjeux sont
trop importants pour pratiquer la
politique de hsville et justement on
conclut avec ces ces grands dossiers qui
sont là sur la table la dit 2023 l'année
la plus chaude de la planète et la COP
28 devrait être une nouvelle occasion de
réaffirmer les engagements de la COP 21
celle de Paris alors on peut dire que ça
a l'air de rien mais on se souvient qu'à
la dernière COP il certains c'était
essayer à détricoter les engagements je
pense à l'Arabie Saoudite la Chine
notamment et puis on attend des
engagements aussi sur les énergies
renouvelables sur le charbon la
réduction des émissions liées aux
opérations pétrrogazières ou encore sur
l'hydrogène et puis la question du
captage de carbone et puis enfin dernier
sujet et pas des moindres la fameuse
solidarité nord- sudud dont le concept a
été déjà posé mais qui est encore loin
d'être financé et d'où l'importance de
ne pas pratiquer la politique de la
chaise vide effectivement Mik bluon
merid vous allez participer à cette COP
28 tout à fait euh dans quel état
d'esprit est-ce que c'est un grand show
de Green wasing qu'on risque d'assister
ou alors au contraire n profitons-en
posons les posons les enjeux faisons
avancer les la réponse est oui et non
oui et non c'est à la fois un jeu de
green washing et à la fois un jeu
d'acteurs qui n'ont pas le choix que
justement essayer de passer vers des
énergies plus propres dans dans mon
portfolio de de recherche il y a la
dimension hydrogène qui est très
importante et effectivement le sujet
qu'on voit par rapport à adnoc par
rapport au sultan aljber que vous avez
évoqué à l'instant même donc le ministre
de l'énergie des émirats Arab un qui
prés de cette COP c'est que
fondamentalement dans le royaume et puis
au-delà de ça dans le golf il n'y a pas
de distinction entre la décision
politique et la décision business
c'est-à-dire que tout tout business est
politique toute politique est business
donc fondamentalement à partir de là
quand il a été fait le choix il y a déjà
plus d'un an et demi que cette
personnalité qui mélange à la fois une
position politique et une position
business pas démission bien sûr que non
ah mais il y a pas du tout de logique si
on se place dans la logique des des
décideurs du golf en général il n pas du
tout de logique qu'il démissionne au
contraire c'était bien qu'il soit là
parce qu'il permettait à la fois de
faire pousser des sujets climat qui
permettaient effectivement aux Émirats
arabes unis se positionner comme un
acteur du changement dirons-nous tout en
étant évidemment un acteur des problèmes
bien bien évidemment et en même temps
développer du business parce
qu'effectivement pour les Émirats arabes
unis et c'est valable pour l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est valable pour la Norvège
c'est valable pour le Canada et plein
d'autres États encore et bien tout
simplement pour faire le switch pour
faire le changement des énergies
fossiles aux énergies renouvelables et à
l'hydrogène et aux batteries et bien il
faut pouvoir faire les deux à la fois
c'est comme ça qu'il voit les chosesou
Françoise Vimeux dans dans dans les
jours qui précèdent cette COP 28 on y
est encore on est à la veille on a
essentiellement parlé de cette polémique
maintenant on va pouvoir se concentrer
sur les enjeux c'est ce que vous espérez
ah oui alors j'espère vraiment hein
parce que là il y a vraiment un
traitement médiatique avec un angle he
sur la présidence de la de la COP 28
faudrait pas que ça éclipse les enjeux
fondamentaux alors pour moi il y en a
tro euh vous l'avez dit il y a d'abord
le bilan mondial hein de l'accord de
Paris où est-ce qu'on en est est-ce que
les pays ont tenu leurs engagements
est-ce que les engagements sont à la
hausse hein parce que dans le
fonctionnement des cops normalement
chaque année les pays doivent revoir
leurs engagements et proposer des
engagements plus ambitieux après il y a
tout ce qui est la sortie des énergies
fossiles donc là ça veut dire discuter
de la transition énergétique comment on
va faire d'un point de vue technique
comment on va l'organiser quel va être
l'agenda ça inclut l'accompagnement dans
le développement décarboné des pays du
Sud hein cette transition énergétique et
puis dernier point moi qui me semble
important vous vous en avait parlé aussi
c'est la solidarité envers le sud à la
fois sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique et puis sur le financement de
ce qu'on appelle les pertes et dommage
c'est-à-dire les conséquences des
catastrophes climatiques qu'on peut
attribuer au changement climatique et je
voudrais juste rajouter un point le fait
que ça se passe au Moyen-Orient c'est
attendu parce que dans le principe de
fonctionnement des cops il y a une
rotation géographique la COP en 2012
avait eu lieu au
Qatar et donc c'est normal qu'on tourne
par grandes régions du monde et le fait
d'avoir une cop dans un pays qui est
plutôt un modèle par exemple en terme
d'écologie c'est pas forcément un gage
de succès on se rappelle de la COP à
Copenhague en 2009 où finalement il y
avait pas eu d'accord extraordinaire à
la fin donc moi je moi je me dis voilà
les yeux sont rivés sur les Émirats
arabes unis je pense que c'est important
pour eux leur image et peut-être je suis
très naïve voilà mais j'espère quand
même j'attends beau et puis
malheureusementfin c'est une réalité
jusqu'à pr du contraire on peut pas se
passer de des énergies fossiles pour
encore quelques années sur sur la
planète mais c'est le sujet c'est
l'opportunisme tout à fait des Émirats
arabes unis et d'autres États en fait le
le point qui va être clé on le voit déjà
depuis deux éditions de la COP là ça va
être la troè fois on voit que
l'hydrogène est le sujet clé de ces COP
pour une raison simple c'est qu' permet
ce sujet d'hydrogène de ramener à la
table des négociations ceux qui veulent
développer les énergies renouvelables et
les États et les compagnies aussi qui
ont intérêt à essayer de garder le plus
possible des énergies fossiles en
faisant évidemment ce changement vers
les renouvelables et donc
fondamentalement ce qu'on a vu c'est que
les négociat au niveau de la COP aurait
pu tout à fait complètement partir en en
cacahuète malheureusement en 2021 et en
2022 et à chaque fois ce sont ces
acteurs là Arabie Saoudite Canada et
évidemment émirat Arab Unis qui ont dit
non non mais attendez avec l'hydrogène
on va pouvoir rassembler tout le monde
autour de la table c'est le cas aussi
d'un groupe comme Total qui fait encore
une immense majorité de son chiffre
d'affaires sur les énergies fossiles
mais qui est aussi un très très gros
investisseur sur les énergies
renouvelable total qui fait partie des
partenaires de de polarp évidemment ça
vous a eu des critiques de toute façon
dès qu'on dit total énergie h pourquoi
vous avez accepté ou peut-être même
cherché ce
partenariat le principal P de carbone
océanique c'est l'océan Austral oui ça
fait 12 ans que je travaille sur ce
projet la première démarche ça a été de
dire il faut concerner les entreprises
qui émettent beaucoup de gaz carboné il
faut quand même comprendre que c'est pas
total qui grille tout le fouel qui va
chercher vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ce qui est important pour ces
entreprises c'est qu'elles modèent leurs
impacts dans leurs activit é ça c'est
une chose il y a autre chose aussi pour
montrer la complexité du problème
revenons à l'Europe c'est c'est c'est
plus facile de réagir de comprendre
quand vous avez l'Allemagne par exemple
qui est revenue au charbon qui a qui qui
attendait beaucoup du Nordstream 2
malheureusement il est pas donc ils sont
revenus au charbon ils avaient
l'opportunité de garder deux centrales
nucléaires encore ils les ont fermés ils
sont restés au charbon la Chine marche à
60 % au charbon l'Australie marche à 35
% au charbon donc on par la Pologne la
Pologne aussi la Pologne est très bien
placé si vous voulez donc une des
premières à à réduire considérablement
c'est le charbon c'est le premier
émetteur si vous voulez dans l'industrie
voilà donc quand on voit la difficulté
qu'il y a par exemple dans la discussion
entre la France et l'Allemagne oou
l'Allemagne ne veut pas considérer que
l'énergie nucléaire comme une énergie
non carbonée euh parce que c'est des
histoires de business vous voyez bien
que on est là dans un milieu très
diplomatique et très économique
effectivement moi je suis d'accord avec
vous j'ai l'espoir tout le temps parce
que si c'est si ces C n'existaient pas
ça pourrait de plus en plus dramatique
quoi ce sont des balises qu'il faut
mettre régulièrement quoi Mathieu moi je
suis étonné que le nucléaire fasse pas
partie des grands sujets de discussion
forcément à la COP alors il fait partie
des sujets de discussion et là pour le
coup les Émirats arabes unis essayent de
pousser le sujet du nucléaire aussi le
problème par rapport au nucléaire il est
assez simple ici c'est que tout le monde
c'està-dire les États qui sont les plus
polluants aujourd'hui n'envisagent pas
du tout une électrification massive de
leur économie avec de grands réseaux de
grandes grilles électriques comme on
peut avoir en Europe com on peut avoir
en France typiquement un pays comme les
États-Unis par exemple n'ont pas la
grille électrique que nous avons ici et
donc fondamentalement quand ils
imaginent le nucléaire c'est plutôt
aujourd'hui des nucléaires de petite
taille c'est des petits réacteurs
modulaires c'est du petit nucléaire pas
du gros comme on connaît chez nous allez
je reviens au au thème principal de
notre débat la la fonte des glaces
polais on va parler de ces ces nouvelles
routes commerciales qui sont en train de
naître avec des projets d'exploitation
et cetera Françoise je commence avec
vous est-ce que on a on a on a parlé du
du temps long et du fait que là on on
finalement on subissait les conséquences
de de de décisions ou de modèles
économiques très très ancien est-ce
qu'il y a un un risque là aussi de CER
vicieux c'estàdire que plus on va
euh exploiter ces régions qui ne
l'étaient pas plus on risque d'aggraver
la situation ou pas d'ailleurs oui alors
bon il y a plusieurs choses d'abord
quand on parle des des nouvelles routes
hein ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
les dernières études elles nous montrent
que on s'attend à partir de de 2030 2050
ou à
avirirôt des mois de septembre où on pas
de banquise au niveau de l'Artique pas
de banquise ça veut dire moins de 1
million de de kilomètr carrés he dans
dans le langage scientifique donc ça
permettrait effectivement d'ouvrir des
routes maritime pour le
transport moi je à mon avis he c'est
c'est ce qui a été dit le problème c'est
pas tant d'ouvert d'ouvrir les routes
maritime c'est que quand on enlève de la
surface blanche pour de la la remplacer
par de la surface sombre et bien on a
une absorption plus forte de l'énergie
solaire donc en fait on amplifie le
réchauffement localement c'est pour ça
que l' ou c'est pas parce qu'on utilise
ces routes maritimes je pense pas avec
la connaissance que j'ai voilà en tout
cas avec la connaissance que j'ai je
n'en ai pas l'impression après s'il y a
un flux énorme de pquebo on va peut-être
avoir des problèmes de pollution
atmosphérique et ça ça pose aussi un
problème parce que si on a des
particules de couleur foncée qui se
déposent sur des surfaces en en neigé
bah rebelotte on a le même problème h
ouais mikon Mered qui est intéressé par
ces nouvelles routes commerciales
j'imagine qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
prêt à investir ou qui ont déjà investi
tout le monde tout le monde tout le
monde c'est-à-dire que évidemment il y a
les huit états de l'Arctique même al on
va pas tous les énumérés mais évidemment
c'est pour la plupart des pays qui sont
alliés hein de de de la France
évidemment plus la Russie on a de
l'autre côté un certain nombre de pays
qui sont pas dans cette zone arctique
mais qui ont des intérêts économiques
que ce soit sur le volet énergie et là
on a les énergies fossiles on a aussi
les renouvelables l'hydrogène que ce
soit sur le secteur minier comme par
exemple pour alimenter le secteur de la
batterie évidemment et de la transition
énergétique mais quand vous dites ça ça
veut dire quoi on pourrait exploiter des
mines là où on ne le faisait pasant on
pourrait c'est on fait c'est-à-dire que
c'est déjà une réalité en fait quand il
y a il y a 10 15 ans on parlait de
projets en Arctique tout simplement des
projets aujourd'hui ils sont tout à fait
concrets et si je me si je reviens un
petit peu même en arrière ça fait déjà
plus de 100 ans qu'on exploite du
pétrole et du gaz en Arctique ça fait
déjà plus de 150 ans qu'on exploite du
charbon en arti ça fait 500 ans qu'on
exploite les ressources marines de
l'Arctique c'est pas nouveau du tout ce
qui est nouveau par contre c'est la
magnitude à laquelle on exploite
aujourd'hui quand on imagine développer
des giga projets qui existent
aujourd'hui déjà dans l'Arctique russe
dans l'Arctique norvégien dans
l'Arctique américain de pétrole de gaz
de fait ces projets là sont directement
polluants et si vous me permettez juste
une phrase en France évidemment on a
beaucoup parlé de l'interdiction de
l'arrêt de l'importation du gaz russe
suite à la guerre en Ukraine
fondamentalement aujourd'hui en 2022 et
en 2023 on importe en France toujours du
gaz naturel liquéfié de Russie et il y a
qu'un seul endroit où on le fait en
Russie c'est en Arctique ouais il y a
pas de sanctuirisation jean-loutiem non
il faut comprendre quand on parle de
l'exploitation de ces routes que vous
avez soulevé bien sûr la banquise fond
mais elles font essentiellement à la fin
de l'été on le voit mais tous les hivers
ça regèle ou donc c'est N et elle fait
aujourd'hui elle faisait dans les années
80 elle faisait 1,80 2 M m d'épaisseur
aujourd'hui ce qui disparaît c'est la
vie la glace pluriannuelle vous voyez
parce qu'elle disparaî C et c'est de la
jeune glace qui arrive qui fait 80 cm 12
200 mais c'est c'est quand même un
obstacle à la navigation il n'y a pas de
compagnie aujourd'hui standard qui
investissent dans des brises glace il y
en a très peu ce ça devient intéressant
et les chinois se'en sont aperçus les
Chinois attendent que le le ce que vous
disiez c'est que le Pôle Nord ne soit
plus englacé c'est-à-dire que la route
ne sera plus le nord-est ni le
nord-ouest ça sera direct being pôle
Nord Islande et là les Chinois ont
investi ils veulent acheter
effectivement de quoi faire en Islande
un port de Port de conteneur ça sera
tout droit ils ont déjà commencé à
travailler sur leur brise glace c'est
cette route directe ils cherchent à
faire pour économiser parce que nord-est
vous dépendez des rues c'est compliqué
nord-ouest il y a encore des clés de
passage difficile à faire est-ce qu'on
peut juste rappeler téléspectateur et à
moi-même à qui appartient l'Arctique et
à qui appartient
l'Antarctique
bien j'y vais j'y vais merci j'adore les
questions pédagogues alors les huit
États qui qui détiennent donc l'Arctique
on a SEP États qui sont bien connus les
États-Unis le Canada les États-Unis
l'Alaska faut pas oublier l'Alaska c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont effectivement en
Arctique le Canada donc le Danemark avec
le Groenland qui est un outremire donc
du Danemark l'Islande bien sûr la
Norvège la Suède la Finlande ça c'est
les SEP états qu'on pourit qualifier
d'occidentaux puis vous avez la Russie
qui représente 53 % de la côte de cet
Océan Arctique donc ces territoires là
c'est chez eux et donc ces territoires
là ces populations là ces décideurs
politiques là ne veulent pas que des
population ou des politiciens comme des
Français des Chinois et autres viennent
leur dire quoi faire ça c'est la
première difficulté donc non ça peut pas
être sanctuirisé de cette manière-là
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'Antarctique
la situation est différente dans le sens
où vous avez SEP États dont la France
qui ont émis des revendications
territorial avant la signature du Traité
sur l'Antarctique qui date de 1959 et ce
Traité sur l'Antarctique dit dit quoi il
dit et c'est la même chose pour la lune
ou pour l'espace par exemple que les
revendications territoriales sont gelées
mais pour autant on n'empêche pas les
pays qui ont émis ces revendications
territoriales comme la France
l'Argentine le Royaume-Uni d'administrer
ces territoire comme si c'était les
leurs c'est comme ça que en France
typiquement en terradelli on a des
représentants du gouvernement qui
portent l'écharpe on a des levées du
drapeau et cetera et cetera c'est la
France en tout cas pour la France alors
je voudrais qu'on parle des réfugiés
climatiques avec ces ces ces chiffres
donné par Oxfam qui parle de 260
millions de réfugiés climatiques en 2030
1,2 milliards en 2050 peut-être qu'ils
sont à prendre avec des pincettes ces
chiffres je veux bien vous entendre
là-dessus mais François zimeux on peut
déjà dire que des réfugiés climatiques
il y en a déjà on a eu il y a quelques
jours l'Australie qui a annoncé
accueillir des les habitants d'un d'un
archipel du Pacifique c'est ça oui alors
en fait aujourd'hui il y a des réfugiés
climatique mais si on parle en terme de
migration c'est des migrations qui
restent très locales qui restent
régionales euh la plupart du temps parce
que les gens ne savent pas où aller
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
les grandes catastrophes euh avaient des
impacts sur des pays particulièrement
vulnérables et donc des pays pauvres et
euh voilà les gens restent
malheureusement sur des ruines euh pour
ce qui est euh de de l'avenir là les
chiffres que vous donnez sont vrais par
exemple on sait que d'ici à 2050 on a 1
milliard de personnes euh qui vont être
touchés par l'élévation du niveau marin
ça concerne évidemment les États
insulaires où certains États ne vont
plus être habitabl hein vraiment la
question l'habitabilité est poséeou mais
230 260 millions en 2030 2030 c'est là
c'est ah oui non mais c'est moi je ça
concerne quelis pas étonné ça concerne
quel pays ça peut concerner bangladesch
par exemple ça peut concerner la c'est
tous les pays vulnérables tous les pays
qui ont un littoral particulièrement
vulnérable à la fois à l'élévation du
niveau des mers aux submersion marin et
à l'érosion he qui est un phénomène
naturel amplifié par le changement
climêre Franco et les sécheresses oui et
Paron de franco-français il y a des
terres françaises concernées aussi voilà
ça concerne aussi nos outremèes ça
concerne évidemment certains certains
atols polynésiens ça concerne aussi
Saint-Pierre et miklon puisqu'on a vu
l'isme entre Saint-Pierre entre pardon
mlon et Langlade être attaqué de plus en
plus par les flots provoquant donc une
rupture de de de du lisme potentiel à
moyen long terme donc fondamentalement
oui ça nous touche déjà au-delà de la
France continentale allez on va parler
des conséquen aussi en terme de
biodiversité je propose à audre vetas de
nous rejoindre euh rebonsoir Audrey on
va on va parler de du Mancha empereur
qui pourrait être la première espèce
polaire à disparaître d'ici la fin du
siècle c'est une espèce que le grand
public a appris à connaître avec un
succès au boxofice la Marche de
l'Empereur bien évidemment qui suit le
périple de la reproduction de cette
espèce qui vit en Antarctique alors je
parle de péricle parce que les adultes
font en général des kilomètres pour
atteindre la zone de reproduction les
femelles pondent ensuite un seul œuf
elles le laissent au malâ et elles
partent chercher de la nourriture c'est
donc le mal qui garde l'œuf au chaud et
sans bouger et sans manger un rituel qui
n'a lieu que
l'hiver les manchau empereur sont
menacés par le changement climatique ils
se reproduisent pendant l'hiver en
Antarctique la pompe des ufs se fait à
la fin de l'automne l'éclosion a lieu
pendant l'hiver et les parents les
nourrissent jusqu'à ce qu'ils prennent
leur envol au
printemp alors pour que les petits soi
autonome il faut que leur plumes
deviennent interméable la période qui
précède est donc extrêmement sensible
d'autant qu'on parle de températures qui
peuvent descendre jusqu'à - 45°gr je
parle sous haut de contrôle le problème
c'est que l'EN dernier en plein milieu
de cette période charnière la fonte de
la banquise s'est accélérée c'est ce que
je vais vous montrer c'est des images
satellites là nous sommes le 10 octobre
et ce que vous voyez en noir et bien
c'est l'une des colonies qui est
observée par le British Antarctique
Antarctique pardon surve et là vous
voyez 18 jours plus tard la fonte est
dramatique la col colonie est emporté et
la totalité des poussins est morte noyée
ou de froid parce que la glace s'est
brisée pardon sous leur pâte et il
n'était pas assez mature pour affronter
ces conditions c'est malheureusement ce
qui s'est passé pour quatre des cinq
colonies qui étaient observé c'est le
premier échec majeur de reproduction des
manchau empereur qui est dû au
réchauffement climatique les chercheurs
le prévoyaient depuis un certain temps
c'est la première fois que ça se passe
et que ça se passe sous nos yeux et que
c'est documenté est-ce que ça pourrait
se répéter oui parce qu'en fait les
manchau empereur se reproduisent tout le
temps tous les au même endroit le lieu
de reproduction est donc mis en péril et
d'après les chercheurs ils peuvent
s'adapter mais ça n'ira jamais aussi
vite que le réchauffement climatique si
rien ne change l'espèce pourrait
disparaître d'ici la fin du siècle Thas
merci audre de ces explications Jean-Lou
Étienne votre expédition polarp polarpe
pardon elle va aussi permettre d'étudier
la faune marine dans cet océan austral
oui parce que le le polarp est un navire
silencieux le moteur de propulsion c'est
le courant circum polaire l'énergie on a
6 éoliennes qui nous donnent de
l'autonomie et donc sur ce sur cette
plateforme on va installer des des
hydrophones des micro sous l'eau et par
une écoute passive on va faire un
inventaire de la faunne parce qu'on
connaît la signature sonore de
pratiquement toutes les espèces sauf des
Mancha qu'on ignore un peu mais d'une
manière générale cette écoute passive
permanente on va faire deux fois le tour
ça devrait durer 3 ans donc par une
écoute permanente on va avoir une idée
assez assez claire l'Antarctique si vous
voulez c'est un immense dert de glace et
vie la vie elle est elle est à la
périphérie à la frontière entre l'eau et
la glace où les espèces viennent là pour
se reproduire et repartent en mer et
d'après on sait pas très bien où elles
vont donc le fait de faire un inventaire
comme ça par acoustique d'avoir une idée
un peu de la migration de ces espèces
une fois qu'elles ont quitté le lieu de
ndification ou de naissance François
c'est tout un un écosystème qui qui
souffre avec la fonte des glaces
polaires oui bien sûr c'est tout les les
écosystèmes qui sont à la fois les
écosystèmes marins donc les écosystèmes
sur le le le littoral et puis tous les
écosystèmes qui visent qui vivent pardon
à l'interface banquise et puis océan
mais il y a bien sûr les écosystèmes
mais moi je pense en article aussi aux
sociétés humaines euh parce que euh le
changement climatique affecte leur mode
de vie euh leur leur nourriture leur
patrimoine et il y a quand même 4
millions hein de personnes qui vivent
dans la la région arctique et quand on
sait que ça se réchauffe trois à quatre
fois plus vite hein que la moyenne
mondiale ça vous donne une idée hein de
la manière dont ils sont impactés h euh
Mikel bjoura et pour autant si vous
allez au Groenland par exemple vous
allez avoir effectivement une franche de
la population plutôt jeune plutôt
éduquée urbanisée dans la seule ville la
capitale du Groenland n hook qui va vous
dire effectivement voilà c'est un danger
c'est vrai et puis vous allez avoir
toute un panel de de votant au Groenland
plutôt dans les les périphéries qui vont
vous dire au contraire ah mais non mais
c'est génial le réchauffement climatique
parce que de fait ça nous permet de
développer de nouveaux business
typiquement le renouvelable et
l'hydrogène typiquement vendre de l'eau
typiquement vendre du sable pour le
ciment par exemple en Chine ça permet de
faire remonter les poissons puisque les
poissons évidemment remonte bien sûr
vers le nord et donc d'avoir des
poissons qui ont une plus grande valeur
ajoutée à pêcher donc le secteur de la
pêche trouve un intérêt et au Groenland
on va trouver donc cette polarisation
politique re entre le parti Inuit
attacategit et je vous je vousi pas je
vous épargne le reste euh et d'autres
parties comme chumut où on va retrouver
justement cette diichotomie entre est-ce
qu'il faut être juste des victimes
réchauffement climatique oou est-ce
qu'il faut pas l'embrasser et en en
tirer les bénéfices je trouve que ce
débat qu'on a au Groenland il est à
mettre en regard avec le débat qu'on a
eu tout à l'heure sur la question de des
Émirats arabes unis de la même manière h
dernière conséquence de la fondte des
glaces dont je voudrais parler avec vous
concerne les les virus elle a été
évoquée par Emmanuel Macron c'était lors
de l'ouverture du sommet des pôles
palarsit à Paris on écoute ce phénomène
dont l'effet le plus immédiat et le plus
visible est la fonte des glaces
représente à l'échelle de l'humanité un
défi inédit qui était
évidemment climatique de biodiversité
mais aussi civilisationnelle l'élévation
du niveau de la mer qui submergera de
nombreux littoraux la raréfaction de
l'eau potable les migrations climatiques
la libération du CO2 voir de nouveaux
risques pandémiques avec la fonte du
permafrost toutes ces menaces sont déjà
bien réelles car elles sont pour
beaucoup la résultante d'émission de CO2
déjà libéré par le passé et qui
produiront leurs effets dans les
prochaines décennies
je je voudrais qu'on parle de ces de ces
virus nouveau risques pandémiqu avec la
fonte du permafros Jean-Louis Étienne
dans cette émission Mathieu peut en
témoigner on essaie de pas être
inutilement anxiogène mais bon de quoi
on parle là on parle de virus enfoui
endormi depuis des Frost et qui émergent
aujourd'hui et contre lesquels nous
n'avons pas de système de de défense
juste un exemplaire un exemple quand
tuavais traverser l'Antarctique pendant
ça duréit 7 mois pendant 6 mois on avait
rien puis à un au bout de 6 mois il y a
un petit avion qui est venu venu amener
la nourriture pour les chiens qui nous
manquaient il y en a deux le japonais et
le chinois sont montés à bord pour êre
de jours après ils avaient la
grippe tout pour dire c'est qu'on est
vivait dans un univers complètement
stérile et tout d'un coup la rencontre
avec deux personnes fait qu'ils ont
chopé la ripe tous les deux vous savez
dans notre corps on a plus de bactéries
et de virus que de cellules quoi donc il
y en a effectivement partout on est plus
ou moins immunisé et là émerge avec la
fonte du permafrost sol gelé en
permanence des vieux virus il faut
forcément en avoir peur ben écoutez il
faut les étudier et voir comment on peut
faire face quoi mais on a des je crois
que peuri non il y a il y a un optimisme
obligatoire si vous voulez parce que tu
l'as évoqué on a on a conscience de la
situation et on a une intelligence pour
les solutions c'est ça qu'il faut
essayer de mettre en œuvre quoi ça
demande des investissements ouais Mik
bljon c'est une c'est une problématique
qui est connue depuis longtemps dans le
sens au niveau du Conseil de l'Arctique
qui est l'organe diplomatique de
référence dans la région donc on est
retourné dans le Grand Nord là au niveau
du Conseil de l'Arctique il y a un
réseau de détection des risques des
virus mal ou non connus qui pourrait
réémerger du permafrost qui existe
depuis 1998 donc il y a déjà une
coopération internationale régionale qui
existe par rapport à ce risque- làà il
n'est pas nouveau mais c'est bien que
des pays comme la France ou les Émirats
arabes unis qui en ont parlé aussi
récemment quand ils ont essayé
d'organiser le sommet diplomatique du
trè pôle pour parler de l'Arctique de
l'Antarctique et de l'Himalaya petit à
petit que ces états qui sont pas du tout
en artique
ça peoucher a Françis on on a quasiment
pas parlé de de N glaciers qui eux aussi
sont sont menacés est-ce que cette
problématique est la même dans des
glaciers c'est est-ce qu'il y a des
virus en fruit qui pourrai ressortir oui
alors bon moi je fantasme pas trop sur
les virus au niveau du permafrost je
suis plus inquiète des dégagements de de
gaz à effet de serre à la fois méthane
et puis dioxyde de carbone qui pourrait
être créé par l'activité de bactéries
hein qui se remettrait à finalement
dissoudre la matière organque qui est le
permafrost en
dégelant du2ou oui alors du méthane et
puis du méthane et puis les les et les
les bactéries en fait qui sont comme
vous libérez finalement le sol n'est
plus gelé hein vous allez avoir de la
végétation de la matière organique donc
les bactéries en fait vont la dégrader
et on va avoir des émissions de de gaz à
effet de ser donc je suis plus inquiète
là-dessus après pour revenir à nos
glaciers je suis pas très inquiète des
des virus en revanche ils vont
disparaître on sait que d'ici 10 à 15
ans dans les Pyrénées nous n'aurons plus
de glaciers euh même sort dans les Alpes
pour les glaciers qui sont à moins de
4000 m d'altitude et au-delà de 4000 m
on aura une surface glaciaire qui
restera 5 à 20 % de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc il faut vraiment se
rendre compte que ce sont les premières
victimes pour le coup chez nous de ce
réchauffement climatique et donc des
paysages qui vont être complètement
modifiés j'allais dire heureusement en
France on est on ne fait pas partie des
régions qui dépendent euh énormé du
ruissellement des glaciers quoi que le
débit de nos rivières en été en dépend
et donc les écosystèmes niveau des des
cours d'eau va va monter alors c ça fond
mais quand vous n'en avez plus ça il y
en a plus et ça c'est un vrai problème
par exemple en Asie centrale ou dans les
ZES sudaméricaine ou pendant la saison
sèche finalement les glaciers sont une
ressource en eau il faut rappeler que je
crois que c'est 2/3 de l'irrigation
mondiale ind dépend du ruissellement des
glaciers donc tant que ça coule et que
ça fond bah vous êtes heureux quand il y
a plus de glacier ça devient difficile
bon la France a obtenu enfin c'est
quasiment sûr l'organisation des Jeux
d'Hiv 2030 ça fait partie des infos
c'est pas sur quelle neige positif ça
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour pour
la France un dernier mot sur le le
permafrost amica Blon Mered est-ce qu'il
y a là aussi le fait que il fond pardon
moi je suis un peu basique je suis
beaucoup moins pointu que vous mais
est-ce que ça facilite des exploitations
minières ou alors pas du tout ça n'a
rien à voir ah alors je vais vous dire
oui et non ça facilite certaines
certaines choses dans le sens où
effectivement ça peut théorie donnait
accès à des zones qui étaient plutôt
difficiles d'accès jusqu'à maintenant
mais en réalité si le sol qui est sous
votre usine par exemple de gaz naturel
liqufié et trop meuble bah de fait ça va
avoir un impact sur vos infrastructures
et on l'a vu ça a généré des fuites ça a
généré des pollutions majeures et cetera
c'est la raison pour laquelle
typiquement sur un grand projet comme
celui de Yamal LNG donc dans la
péninsule du Yamal dans l'Arctique russe
un projet notamment porté par Total mais
c'est pas les seules ce qu'ils ont
décidé de faire c'est de mettre 60000
puits euh pardon 60000 pieux dans le
permafrost sous l'usine ces pieux vont
être au niveau de la surface de chaque
pieux à une température de - 4° celus de
manière que au contact entre le pieu et
le permafrost bah le permafrost ne
dégèle pas ni l'été ni l'hiver moyen en
quoi ça permet de stabiliser l'usine et
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
sécurité d'exploitation je dis pas que
c'est bien je dis voilà le genre de
solution qu'on met en œuvre on préfère
mettre ça en œuvre plutôt que de se
passer des énergies
merci beaucoup technolutionniste et
sobriété les deux en même temps on va
rappeler les bons messages merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Jean-Lou
Ettine Étienne vous avez préfacé
l'ouvrage Grand Nord un voyage dans le
CERC article qui est publié chez glena
et puis les mondes polaires c'est le
titre de votre livre mikable Dujour
Mered au presse universitaire de France
je vous dis à demain à 18h 22h sur
Public Sénat et noté que l'invité de la
matinale demain auiane Mancini reçoit le
porte-parole du rassemblement national
Laurent jacobelli le député RN de Melle
bonne
[Musique]
soirée allez on va la tourner tout le
monde en place et action Michel c'était
votre programme avec Yoni et Michel
paulnaref qui ne serait pas là s'il
avait mieux géré son épargne et je fais
quoi
[Musique]
là VO pour revoir votre
programme sur
publsena.fr les nouvelles de l'attentat
dans le grand magasin Tati trois
personnes auraient été tuées par le
commando il est 17h05 hier place Charles
de Gaulle une bombe explose lorsque il y
a eu les attentats de Charlie et aussi
ceux sur l'hypercachè et et aussi sur la
policière de Montrouge il y a eu un
soulèvement
j'ordonne que tous les moyens soit
employé partout ils ne passeront pas en
ce qui concerne le terroriste la réponse
c'est l'unité nationale vous avez une
rage c'est l'inhumanité la barbarie le
terrorisme ne détruira pas la République
car c'est la République qui le détruira
président le prix à payer face au
terrorisme un documentaire inédit écrit
par Michel cota et Patrice duamel
réalisé par Pauline per vendredi à 22h
sur public Senat et dès à présent sur
publicsenat.fr je me sens par moment
mauvais médecin je vais trop vite j'ai
peur de faire des erreurs de passer à
côté de quelque chose de potentiellement
grave y a-t-il un problème de mal-être
et de maltraitance dans le monde du soin
c'est la question hautement sensible que
j'ai exploré dans mon film soignant à
cœur ouvert réalisé avec Adrien Benoliel
un tabou levé par les soignants
eux-mêmes il y a quelques jours dans une
tribune du Monde nous n'avons pas choisi
ce métier pour vous faire subir cette
violence et être maltraitant disent--il
comment répondre à ce cri d'alarme le
mal-être des soignants débouche-t-il sur
des formes de maltraitance je vous
retrouve juste après le documentaire
pour en débattre avec nos
invités votre documentaire suivi d'un
monde en doc présenté par Rebecca
fitousi samedi à 21h sur public
Sena
I